what is it that makes a person a hero is
it a trait that you're born with
something that you can inherit passed
down from generation to generation is
someone still a hero if they never save
a life but improve the lives of the
people that matter to them do you really
need a magic hammer an enchanted suit of
armor or a tragic origin story in order
to become a hero or can you still be
heroic as an ordinary everyday person
through the simplest of kind deeds maybe
it only takes a few moments in a
lifetime to be a hero moments when you
are given the chance to overcome
adversity or conquer a personal flaw
perhaps learning how to deal with defeat
and get back up after rather than
learning how to never be defeated is the
essence of heroism we can all be heroes
every single one of us and in a way we
already are everyone is the hero of
their own story and if you want any
further proof of that then maybe you
should take a look inside
scp-1230 an unassuming book is presented
to you its hardcover is dark green but
other than that there is absolutely
nothing remarkable about it that you can
notice but little do you know this book
that you hold in your hands is none
other than
scp-1230 so what's inside surely it must
be an important anomalous artifact if
the scp foundation has an interest in it
perhaps it's filled with ancient spells
or a mathematical formula to calculate
the exact mass of the fabric of reality
now if you're expecting every page to be
full you'd be disappointed in fact only
the first page you open in the book will
have anything written on it the rest
will appear blank and this can change
depending on which page you open first
resetting every time the book is closed
again however the phrase you will find
written on that page will always stay
the same when opening scp-1230
you will see the words a hero is born
what happens after you read these words
well not much at least not right away in
fact you won't notice any active effects
after reading scp-1230 for quite some
time until that is you fall asleep and
as you sleep you begin to dream now most
dreams are pretty disjointed sometimes
fragments of memories or your deepest
most random thoughts of course other
times it's a fear a long-held and
deep-rooted phobia or manifestation of
anxiety brought to the surface for a
while in the form of a nightmare only to
be forgotten by the time you've woken up
perhaps that's why so many people look
for the deeper meaning to their dreams
to get a better understanding of
themselves but this dream is different
far more vivid and memorable with a
meaning that is a lot easier to discern
in this stream you find yourself as the
hero of your own story the protagonist
of a fantastical adventure it's more
than an ordinary dream it looks sounds
smells feels as real as the ordinary
world you know you will find yourself at
the center of a fantasy world where you
are the hero destined to aid this
troubled land to bring peace and save
the world the fantasy you find yourself
in is different depending on who you are
it's a dreamscape that has been
tailor-made for your enjoyment and your
epic quest awaits on the path laid out
in front of you but where do these
bespoke fantasy adventures come from
does the scp-1230 book itself bestow
these dreams on a reader or is there
some other force at play that creates
worlds where the dreamer is the hero
well actually yes there is and his name
is the bookkeeper or scp-1230-1
he looks exactly as you would imagine
him too an old man adorned in a dark
green cloak with a long beard sometimes
appearing to dreamers in order to guide
them picture gandalf from the lord of
the rings books but instead of the grey
or the white the bookkeeper is gandalf
the green in every dream caused by
scp-1230
the bookkeeper appears as the
personification of the book itself often
aiding dreamers willingly offering them
counsel guidance and help on their
fantastical quests in an experiment to
test the range of scp-1230's anomalous
properties an scp foundation researcher
opened the book and then boarded a
domestic flight spending the night in a
hotel in his hometown even miles away
from the book the researcher still
experienced a fantastical dream and
during this dream he was approached by
scp-1230-1
the bookkeeper was happy to explain the
workings of the book describing how
scp-1230 implanted a dream in the
reader's subconscious mind from the
moment they saw the phrase a hero is
born on the page he claimed that he was
the sole being with the ability to
manipulate what he described as fantasy
scapes and that he enjoyed doing this
aiming to sculpt these fantastical
dreams in such a way that the dreamer
experiencing them would get the most
enjoyment out of being the hero of their
own story thanks to the bookkeeper the
length of the dreams vary they could be
quick only lasting 45 seconds or seem to
last as long as 200 years from the
dreamer's point of view however in the
real world the person experiencing the
bookkeeper's fantasy scape would only
actually be asleep for an average
duration of time
scp-1230 only takes effect on living
beings with the capacity for imagination
in other words only human beings are
affected by the book and are able to
enter their own bespoke fantasy when the
scp foundation attempted to use a
mechanical arm to open scp-1230
the pages remain blank leading the
bookkeeper to explain to a subsequent
dreamer that only beings who can dream
may find the phrase a hero is born
within most animals or any machines that
view the book will not experience its
effects at all so what can a person do
within the fantasy scapes of these
dreams is it an open sandbox to do
anything and everything you can think of
or do these fantastical realms have
their own rules well for a start they do
seem to be completely safe spaces during
testing the foundation conducted a
number of experiments that involve
getting members of d-class personnel to
read scp-1230
and test the limitations of the dream
worlds the bookkeeper created for them
why use d-class personnel to test out
something seemingly as harmless as
scp-1230
because the foundation wanted to know if
a person could die in one of these
dreams one test involved ordering a
d-class to immediately find a way to
terminate himself once he found himself
inside the dream world he awakened after
only 45 seconds of being asleep and
described being at the peak of a volcano
called the ashen spire apparently within
the dream the test subject had been sent
on a quest to recover a sword known as
calydus the blessed blade he said these
names had come to him as if he had known
them all along following the
foundation's orders the d-class
attempted to throw himself into the
volcano before him only to wake up
moments later after feeling intense heat
but suffering no adverse effects in the
real world during the following
experiment another d-class was told to
try and injure himself in the fantasy
scape but not a fatal injury the subject
awoke after six hours of sleep feeling a
numbed pain in the same place he had
attempted to harm himself but this
sensation was never intense in fact it
was barely noticeable in his dream the
d-class said that he had conversed with
the bookkeeper who had shown concern
that the man was trying to cause himself
injury but thanked him for not
terminating himself immediately like the
other rude fellow that had preceded him
so all of this sounds pretty great right
a book that lets someone live out a
fantasy adventure in which they are the
hero of their own bespoke story what
could possibly be the downside well the
downside is this what if someone
preferred their fantasy to the real
world now comes the unfortunate story of
a professor working for the scp
foundation a lifelong fan of tabletop
role-playing games like dungeons and
dragons the professor filled the request
for access to scp-1230
and it was granted he was apparently
shaking with pure excitement after
reading a hero is born in the book he
didn't even wait until later to go to
sleep instead opting to doze off right
then and there at the desk where he'd
read it after the professor had spent 15
entire hours of sleep concern had begun
to spread among the other researchers he
remained sleeping living out his own
fantasy adventure for a further nine
hours spending a total of 24 hours in
the dream world that the book keeper had
made for him when the professor awoke he
appeared to look around the room
confused unsure of where he was when
approached by the foundation's security
personnel medical staff examined him and
explained where he was after which the
professor seemed to regain his memory
after being reminded who he was the
professor excused himself to the
restroom he didn't emerge and 15 minutes
later a member of the medical team went
to check on him sadly the professor was
dead scribbled on the nearby bathroom
wall was one simple phrase his last
words i can't go back to this attempting
to immediately use scp-1230 and make
contact with the bookkeeper another
doctor tried to find the a hero was born
phrase within the pages of the book
however instead the pages were soaking
wet and on every single page the same
message i am so sorry i never intended
for this to happen i just wanted to make
people happy for three weeks the book
stayed like this until the same doctor
placed a sticky note inside
scp-1230 that said i'd like to talk to
you if that's all right that night the
doctor fell asleep and dreamt of being
in a dark void there was only one source
of light in the endless darkness a
street lamp under which he found the
bookkeeper sat in a puddle the old
bearded man was sobbing uncontrollably
his cloak soaking wet with his tears he
explained through his overwhelming
sadness what had happened to the
professor he had such an active
imagination i was able to create a vast
and beautiful universe for him and it
was obvious that he wanted a life like
that for so long he caught good foul
beasts and rescued princesses he built
kingdoms and even raised a family but he
never wanted to leave he delved so far
into his fantasy world that i soon
realized he preferred his dream over the
real world i reminded him that this was
all merely an illusion but he wouldn't
listen to me he stated that if he was
ever forced to leave
he would immediately end his life i
tried to keep him happy for as long as i
could the bookkeeper revealed that from
the professor's point of view the
fantasy life he had lived lasted 200
years as much as the old man had tried
to hold on and keep the professor happy
for as long as possible eventually he
had to release him from the fantasy
scape and as a result the professor had
ended his own life rather than return to
reality
scp-1230 resumed its normal function a
few days later after the doctor left
another note between the pages offering
some friendly advice to the bookkeeper
now it sits quietly on a bookshelf in
the site-12 library surrounded by
fictional novels the perfect material to
inspire more fantasy scapes in the
future we all like to dream that we're
the heroes of our own stories but to
quote the bookkeeper himself her sweet
his dreams may be
eventually we all have to wake up now go
check out
scp-1762 where the dragons went and
scp-348 a gift from dad for more
anomalies that are sure to tug at your
heartstrings